I mean you just plain don't do that that
was just for everybody
[Music]
the next scene is ocean it's the rules
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I mean if
you love someone you shoot them in the
face if you love someone you shoot them
in the face anything funny then we have
anything funny yeah you know I time to
nut up or shut up you know what I think
ya think you need a new language time to
nut up or shut up you need a new line
let's kick some dicks just because it
rhymes doesn't make it a great
catchphrase
it's her prob I don't know I think it
went it right
it worked
yes looks promising
he's so flexible yeah that's what's so
great about him he's very bendy Ohio
whenever you're done with that
that's good hi-c
mm-hmm hi-c yeah the old man is so tiny
can you see that what's his name you're
so tiny
no you're not hey you art no you're not
no you're not you're not
now you're now you're not tiny big tiny
she's adorable
how was that must followed you
hmm those are t8 hundreds at the very
least q7 hundreds actually was no tease
appropriate eat hundreds the first model
it's just great having two of you okay
time to nut up or shut up that sings
very 2009
[Laughter]
okay we got this oh you don't send a boy
to do a man's job we brought him here
we'll take care of it have Adam hasta
LaVista baby Terminator 2 he's so cool
[Applause]
anybody else fine I was to uniquely
annoying uniquely know I love their
chances in the Norview 52 don't be
afraid to ask for help okay describe a
perfect day in Zombieland
[Music]
we're getting good at this I love being
back with everyone it just kind of feels
like getting to hang out with my buddies
again
it was crazy when we came back because
woody and Jessie both didn't know who I
was I think we could get out what was
working well in the first one and
capitalized on it for this one start
talking you first tell her she Nevada
you know you're coming into a family
experience and so I feel really lucky
that I was able to tap into that this
kind of reminds you of
hello everyone bye Liz Nina they said
didn't you know you're a poor man's
jesse eisenberg I said what
hi I'm Columbus Madison know why she's
still alive because zombies eat brains
and she got in a beam of light in a
world of darkness is the non-judgmental
way of describing her it felt like it
would be a fantastic standalone movie
even if it wasn't associated with the
first time for sure that sings very 2009
didn't see that coming right the thing
that you're gonna like is just how we
get along or how we don't get along guys
they're much more afraid of us than we
are of them you'll be the first to die
but I like your enthusiasm you might die
thank you for your sacrifice
hands down greatest I ever saw well
maybe not the greatest he was capable of
things you would literally not believe
was he like a big deal or something the
greatest Nabi hunter of all time
the Jeezy hOAT the Gaza Jota he's
Tallahassee
well I first met Tallahassee and
Tallahassee playing ball way back away
in college you sure like an online
course can you play in an online course
is that like a computer game version or
something didn't you get hit a lot like
in the head I'm except that would kind
of explain something I did play a little
ball back in my day I had this move
called the Tallahassee two-step step one
hit whatever's in front of you step two
repeat he truly seemed to enjoy every
tackle I mean nobody else took that much
joy in hitting people and he hit like a
minivan no it's a minivan I mean once
the zombies took over sports just went
away
zombie hunting that was the only sport
left those were dark days a lot of ball
players did really well in the early
years after the outbreak but nobody did
it like Tallahassee you know I just came
natural to me must be in my blood he was
the biggest star in the only sport left
in the whole world SportsCenter top ten
every night until everyone at ESPN
turned into a zombie he does have a
beautiful swing Newt swings his tackling
form textbook I don't know why he always
tackles textbooks but I guess he had
trouble in school could you describe a
relationship with Tallahassee with a
facial expression
he was a legend legend is strong that
will go right to his head the game has
been very good to me
I've been blessed to get to do what I
love but the thing about the sport of
zombie hunting is there's no final
buzzer you play until you can't and some
folks think you know maybe Tallahassee
can't anymore
[Music]
the great ones rise to the occasion when
the moment comes when it's crunch time
Tallahassee is still the man I want
taking the shot honestly it's kind of on
the downslope it's a very steep
downslope like a like a cliff they say
he's not the same he's lost a step great
athletes they just can't quit the game
even when their bodies tell them it's
time his cat-like reflexes
but dead cat you know I hit his knee and
a week later he kicked me do I believe
that Tallahassee can get up off the mat
one more time
I certainly pretend to when he's around
been told I'm too slow too old too
unfocused what was the question again
athletes don't always get to decide when
they're done I think the game decides
for you
we're so written for me
I sleep in here as best I can because
it's soundproof and so people can't hear
me shrieking at the top of my lungs
crying myself to sleep waiting for the
zombies and the sweet release of death
for me I mean the upside was you know my
first love is golf and golf and zombie
honey kind of go hand in hand we're
gonna call this one big swing get it
thank God for tape I will wreck Assam be
with this Golf Club
this right here lint roller crafted it
myself with some tape and candlestick
thank yourself huh I'm just trying my
best man I mean I don't know how you do
a wheelchair is anything on I what is
this this is Sports Center I'm Scott Van
Pelt it's been 30 years since the zombie
apocalypse
[Music]
do you know what I would like I don't
give a [ __ ] what you might have survived
by using their wish nothing personal how
could that not be personal that's like
my whole thing yeah you're right it was
personal October 18 what made you do it
and don't say descriptive can this be
just between us drugs cost money
didn't see that coming right
they're much more afraid of us than we
are of them you'll be the first to die I
like your enthusiasm you might die yeah
thank you for your sacrifice from the
directly advance
me too right oh yes
and my juices get booyah Casablanca
Oh God well I think I would have made a
damn fine president I think those cigars
were left over from the Clinton
administration Academy Award nominee
what do you Harrelson let's kick some
dicks
let me Award nominee Jesse Eisenberg
right now right now Academy Award
nominee Abigail Breslin any award winner
Emma Stone that sings very 2009
[Music]
you